NO COMPROMISE INSIGHT AND LOTS
OF MEMBERS HAVE DECIDED TO GO
HOME FOR CHRISTMAS.
JOINING ME NOW, TRUMP FORMER
CAMPAIGN MANAGER HE IS THE
FORMER DEPUTY SECRETARY OF STAT
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU,
BECAUSE WE HAVE HEARD THIS
BUILDUP NOW FROM ABOUT 72 HOURS.
IN EARNEST.
THE BUILDUP, WERE GOING TO PLAY
A LITTLE MONTAGE OF THE MEDIA
DECLARING THAT WHAT'S HAPPENED
WITH MATISS RESIGNING, THE
PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN, SO
FAR NO WALL FUNDING, WHICH MEAN
OF COURSE THE END.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IS THIS THE BEGINNING OF THE
END OF WHAT WE'VE KNOWN.
>> IT REALLY IS A PRESIDENCY AN
CRISIS LIKE WE HAVEN'T SEEN.
>> I MEAN WE COULD HAVE PLAYED
ANOTHER FOUR OR FIVE SOUNDBITES
THAT I ACTUALLY THOUGHT WE HAD
THERE BUT THIS IS THE DRUMBEAT.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE STARTING TO
ABANDON HIM.
THE WALL STREET JOURNAL IS
CRITICIZING HIM.
THE ALLIES ARE UP IN ARMS.
WHERE DOES THIS STAND NOW?
ANY ISSUES WITH MESSAGING THAT
COULD BE TWEAKED OR CHANGED TO
GET THE NARRATIVE TERMS IN
CHARGE, HE'S PROTECTING THE
COUNTRY?
TAKE A LOOK, IT'S VERY SIMPLE,
THIS PRESIDENT MADE A PLEDGE
DURING THE CAMPAIGN I THINK IT
WAS THE BIGGEST PLEDGE HE MADE
AND RECEIVED THE LARGEST AMOUNT
OF APPLAUSE ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL AND NOW HE HAS TO FULFILL
IT.
THE WEAK REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP
OF THE LAST TWO YEARS IN
CONGRESS HAVE FAILED TO DELIVER
IT.
THEY ASKED THE PRESIDENT OUGHT
TO SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT
BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
BECAUSE THEY'RE FEARFUL IT'S
GOING TO HURT THEM IN THE
MIDTERMS AND THEY PROMISED TO
PUT THE FUNDING IN FOR THE WALL
AFTER THE MIDTERM ELECTION.
ONCE AGAIN THEY FAILED THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
PRESIDENT THAT WE'VE HAD ENOUGH.
BECAUSE OF YOUR SHOW AND JIM IN
JIM JORDAN COMING ON FOR ME FOU
TIMES, SHAME ON ME.
PRESIDENT SAW THAT AND SAID WE
CAN'T TOLERATE THIS.
IF WE DON'T GET THE FUNDING FOR
THE WALL NOW, IT WILL NEVER COM
TO FRUITION.
>> HOW DO THE DEMOCRATS GO TO
THE VOTERS IN THE COUNTRY.
WE KNOW THAT WE SPEND
$18 BILLION A YEAR.
ON HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
MUCH MORE ON PUBLIC EDUCATION.
FOR COMPASSION OF PEOPLE AND
WHAT WE DO.
THE DEMOCRATS CAN'T FIND
$5 BILLION TO GET THE BORDER
FORTIFICATION GOING.
WHY ARE WE WORRIED ABOUT OTHER
COUNTRIES AND NOT FOCUSING ON
OUR OWN?
>> WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
AMERICAN BORDER.
THERE IS THAT WAS ALREADY AGREE
TO ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS BY THE
SENATE.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT THE
APOSTLE IT WASN'T JUST ABOUT
BUILDING THE WALL, IT WAS THAT
MEXICO WOULD PAY FOR IT AND NOW
WITH THE PRESIDENT ASKING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO PAY FOR IT.
I DON'T WANT TO PAY FOR A BORDE
WALL.
>> BUT YOU'RE FINE WITH PAYING
FOR THE $18 BILLION A YEAR FOR
HEALTHCARE?
THAT'S COOL WITH YOU?
>> WHEN PEOPLE.
>> OKAY, SEE HER ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT.
>> THE KEY THING HERE IS THE
BORDER WALL DOESN'T HAVE THE
VOTES.
YOU WILL HAVE LESS WITH VOTES I
ABOUT TWO WEEKS.
THE VOTES AREN'T THERE.
IT'S THEORETICAL.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GET THE
MONEY FROM THIS CONGRESS.
THEY HAVEN'T FOR TWO YEARS SO
WHY ARE WE SHUTTING DOWN FOR TH
GOVERNMENT FOR A VOTE THAT WILL
WORK IN THE PRESIDENTS FAVOR.
>> WE DON'T DEAL IN THE REALM O
FACTS WE HAVE 25 PERCENT OF THE
GOVERNMENT NONESSENTIAL
EMPLOYEES, NONESSENTIAL SERVICE
ARE COVERED UNDER THE SHUTDOWN.
EVERY TIME I HEAR NONESSENTIAL
THINK WHY ARE THESE PEOPLE IN
THE GOVERNMENT AT ALL?
WE ONLY NEED THESE PEOPLE.
>> WE DON'T REALLY NEED TO, STA
HOME.
>> IT'S CRAZINESS.
>> IT'S ALSO SUCH A SCAM.
WHEN THEY HAVE THE NONESSENTIAL
EMPLOYEES STAND HOME, AND THEY
ARE STAYING HOME FOR THE EXTRA
DAY.
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT WE OPENED,
WE BACK PAY THEM FOR ALL THE
DAYS THEY DIDN'T COME TO WORK.
BUT IT'S INTERESTING.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL PAY FO
THE WALL.
WE'VE SEEN THAT FROM GO FUND ME
WHO'S BEEN RUNNING FOR THREE OR
FOUR DAYS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL PAY FO
SECURITY.
THE FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOVED ONE
KILLED BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER WILL
PAY FOR THE WALL.
YOU ASK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
PAY FOR IT, WE HAVE THE MONEY
FOR IT, THE CASH FOR CLUNKERS
PROGRAM UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS THAT
$3 BILLION BOONDOGGLE TO KEEP
PEOPLES CARS AWAY AND THROW
MONEY IN THE TRASH.
>> I'VE GOT TO SAY TO BOTH OF
YOU, THIS IS FROM THE DEMOCRATS
TO THE REPUBLICANS, I THINK BOT
HAVE HANDLED THIS ABYSMALLY.
IT IS ABYSMAL HANDLING OF THE